the first idea was can we create
something that is very cool and that
grew into trying to think about
designing a diode that could be the most
efficient diode for the LED market first
couple years almost zero revenue mostly
innovating thinking trial and error
conceptualization talking to folks that
point you would probably call the
company more of a conceptual idea than a
functioning business the real innovation
comes from taking that base technology
and creating a system around it that
could maximize its potential and we saw
that high output lighting in rigorous
environments there was a demand for that
type of technology and it was really
going unmet and that was the aha moment
we've done projects for the US Army
where we've lit outdoor venues that are
training venues were involved with
lighting Warren stamping plant for
Chrysler we're doing quite a few venues
for the paper industry and for the steel
industry food processing we did a
project for a frito-lay you just bought
big we just thought we were a bigger
company than paper we really were
there's definitely a capital challenge
with adopting this technology we
targeted opportunities where we thought
the economics were compelling paybacks
that were less than two years in some
cases 18 months and then we looked for
financial partners as the markets
growing there are new partners entering
that have the capital and understanding
technology and are willing to fund these
projects based bombing savings in many
cases and the paybacks projected from
those savings
we were innovative solutions that we
thought could meet a broader application
market which include outdoor stadiums
and we targeted at the university of
phoenix we knew they were going to host
a Super Bowl in 2015 for us it was a
great place to demonstrate our
technology to a worldwide audience
especially in light of the fact that two
years ago when the lights went out at
the New Orleans Superdome and it took 20
minutes or so for the lights to come
back on we asked ourselves is that the
right places to park Brett bend of
course we said sure sure let's challenge
ourselves with with what we can
accomplish I would say we have an equal
creative business strategy to our
innovation technology strategy is
fascinating and it's a
multitrillion-dollar market worldwide
over the next generation of time